[Applause]  you  this is one of my favorite is some our  Christmas objects because it has these  little jingle bells but it also sounds  good when you scrape it like this I  think we should put this I love these  I have some more would you like one  Wow it's really beginning to feel like  Christmas in here  we don't only celebrate Christmas here  we also celebrate Hanukkah which is why  I brought up this little Hanukkah Tim  oh wait but look there's something  inside it's a treat these aren't just  any dreidels their sports trails see a  soccer ball  we've got one final little treat for you  well a bunch of little jingle bells what  a great gift  Wow you know I feel so relaxed now I  think this is going to be the most  relaxing Christmas thanks for watching  and make sure to subscribe to this  channel for more videos